So congratulations. You've made it to the end of this unit. And we've covered
quite a bit here. You've learned about breaking programs into modules and how
this can make it easier to manage complexity, and learning how to manage
complexity is one of the most important, perhaps the most important, skill that
you can develop as a programmer. And there are lots of tools for this. One is
modules. The other one that we've learned about in this class is defining your
own types by using classes. You'll use some of these ideas in the problem set to
make some improvements to this search engine code. They won't change the
behavior of the search engine but they'll make it easier to modify and make it
easier to understand and break into pieces. If you're paying really close
attention, you might be curious what's going on with these magic init and magic
str methods before we define them because you'll note when we tried to print out
a restaraunt object, we didn't get an error. We got something, just not
something very useful. And we also were able to initialize these objects before
we defined init. So there was something there already. We didn't get an error
about an undefined attribute because something was there. What's strange is,
well, we didn't actually create anything explicitly that was there. What we'll
do next class is explain what was there. And understand how the idea of
inheritance will allow us to build lots and lots of classes, reusing code from
previous classes. Hope to see you there for the next unit.